FEMALE SPEAKER:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
FEMALE SPEAKERS:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
FEMALE SPEAKERS:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: [SPEAKING DUTCH]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
FEMALE SPEAKERS:
[SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ANNOUNCER: Please welcome
Engineering Manager
at Google, Sowmya Subramanian.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SOWMYA SUBRAMANIAN:
Good morning.
Thank you for joining
us today to celebrate
International Women's Day.
This is a global
event, so I want
to encourage you
throughout the day
to use the social media
to express your voice.
Please use #womentechmakers.
I'm super excited to
be part of this event.
I'm here because
like many of you,
I have a degree in
computer science--
a master's in computer
science from the University
of Wisconsin, Madison and a
bachelor's from Mount Holyoke
College.
Also I've been in the
industry for 15 years
since I graduated and one of
the senior women engineers
in YouTube engineering.
And I love being in technology.
This is not always the case.
Many women drop out
technology in school
or even after they
start their career.
Nearly 50% of women
within the first 10 years
of their technical career either
switch professions or quit.
I have not, and I'm confident
each and every one of you
after listening to the
great lineup of speakers
we have today and the events we
have planned will not either.
As technologists and thinkers,
we solve everyday problems.
And we come up with innovative
ways to make things happen.
Women make up 51% of
the world's population.
Yet according to the
Department of Commerce,
women make up only 27% of
all computer science jobs
in the US.
And these numbers are worse when
it comes to leadership roles.
Women are part of 14% of Fortune
500 executive committees,
17% of Congress, and
11% of founder or CEO
positions in venture
backed US firms.
The number of women
studying computer science
is on the decline.
It's nearly 8% below where
we were nearly 10 years ago.
And this is important.
It's important to note
and recognize this
because time and time again we
have seen that diverse and well
balanced teams result in more
effective decision making
and in better product designs.
According to McKinsey,
companies which
have a higher proportion of
women in top management roles
result in higher
returns on investment
and higher earnings
than average.
Catalyst found
out that companies
which have at least
three women as part
of their board of
directors have on average
10% return on investment,
compared to only 6.2%
otherwise.
Universities and companies
are recognizing this
and doing their part
to help bridge the gap.
For instance, Google provides
a great work environment
for women and has strong women
leaders to serve as role models
within the company, many of whom
you'll be hearing from today.
The Women at Google
network of over 5,000
women from 23 countries
is very active.
And Google helps
organize events like this
to raise gender awareness.
As part of our commitment
to advancing computing
and technology at all levels, we
have education and scholarship
programs for aspiring
computer scientists.
Our Generation
Google Scholarships
are aimed at currently
enrolled high school
seniors, undergraduates,
and graduates
who are planning to be
full-time enrolled students
in universities in
the US or Canada.
The Anita Borg
Scholarship is for women
across the world
who are pursuing
a degree in computer science.
And the Women on
the Web program,
which started out as a
community based initiative
to encourage more
women participation
in Google for
Business groups, aimed
at increasing the number
of women entrepreneurs
in technology and
enabling women to succeed
by leveraging the
power of the internet
early on in their start-ups.
This program that
started out in India
has now expanded to
Latin America, Africa,
Southeast Asia, and
the Middle East.
And it focuses on encouraging
women and empowering them
in emerging markets.
From the very beginning,
Google's mission, goal,
and mantra has been focus on the
user and all else will follow.
It turns out our
users are 50% women,
speak different
languages, and come
from different
parts of the world.
And in order to better
understand this diverse user
pace and build great products
and services for them,
we need our teams
to be diverse too.
So Google puts in
a lot of effort
to ensuring that we have
an all inclusive workplace,
and that we reflect
what our users are,
so that we can build out
better products and services.
We also are proactively
looking at ways
in which we can make
the environment better
and empower women further.
For instance, recently our focus
has been on unconscious bias.
Research has shown
that when we are
aware of our
unconscious bias, we
can make more
objective decisions
and have better discussions.
So over 20,000 Googlers
and 80% people managers
have been engaging
in workshops focused
on understanding the science
of how the mind works
to bring together
and have dialogues
across the company about
the unconscious bias
and the effect it has on how
we perceive others, how we
interact with our coworkers,
our clients, and the business
as a whole.
Efforts like this allow us to
make ourselves into a better
company and become a better
workplace and environment.
In honor of International
Women's Day,
Google offices
all over the world
have been hosting
events like this.
I was honored to be a speaker
at an International Women's Day
event in Paris just
this past Wednesday
to around 200 plus attendees.
It is just invigorating
and very energizing
to see and hear people's
aspirations and dreams
in those attendees and also
to hear stories from them
on how the number of
women in computer science
has been increasing in local
colleges and universities.
So these efforts that we
are doing is paying off.
In fact recently when I was
getting ready for these talks,
I found out that in 2014 for
the first time in the history
of University of
California, Berkeley,
an introductory
computer science class
has more women
enrolled than men.
And the slight positive trend
is significant for women
in computer science and
women in technology.
So we have a great
agenda planned for you
with amazing
speakers, some of whom
I have the honor of
working closely with.
And I'm confident by hearing
the inspiring talks from them,
by engaging and networking
with all the different women
engineers who are
here at the event.
All right.
To get started with
the day, I want
to introduce you to our
first keynote speaker,
the VP of Technology from
Nest Labs, Yoky Matsuoka.
A little bit of bio about her.
Prior to joining Nest, she was
Google's Head of Innovation
and a professor of
computer science
at University of Washington.
She got her master's and
PhD in computer science
and electrical
engineering from MIT
and received the MacArthur
Genius Award for her work
in robotics and neuroscience.
So let's welcome
Yoky to the stage.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Thanks.
Well, good morning.
ANNOUNCER: Good morning.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Great.
Well, thanks for being here.
I am incredibly excited to be
here in front of so many women.
This doesn't happen very often,
as you all know about that.
I'm really excited.
It's kind of interesting
to go through thinking
about-- what can I
talk about today?
And I looked at the title
today saying Women Techmakers.
And I realized that
I didn't really
start out as a techmaker.
I had many different
chapters, sometimes low.
Sometimes I wanted to quit.
I wanted to go through all
of those because some of you
might be thinking
something to do,
something to dramatically
change your life.
I've gone through a lot.
Here we go.
Just like all of you
and 50% of people
who live on Earth are
supposed to be women,
we are asked as
we grow up-- what
do you want to be
when you grow up?
Right?
Somehow most of us didn't say
we just want to stay at home.
I don't know why, but
that's what a lot of women
end up doing.
I thought really hard
about it as a kid.
I didn't even understand
what that question meant
for a long time, but
I eventually found it.
And it was this.
I wanted to be a tennis player.
I really loved it.
I played four to six hours,
six to seven days a week,
and really trained for it.
I went to Wimbledon
Junior tournaments.
This was the funnest thing ever.
So I didn't know
anything else, but this
is a picture taken by a
newspaper person in college.
And if you look at
it really carefully,
I'm wrapped around in a mummy
style in all different body
parts.
It turns out my
body didn't keep up
with what I thought I wanted
to be whenever I was asked
the question of what you
want to do when you grow up.
So as my body started
to fall apart,
I wasn't sure what
to do with myself.
I wasn't going to be Monica
Seles or somebody who's
absolutely at the
top of the world.
Then I started to look
at other parts of my
what you want to do
when you grow up.
And I thought, well maybe
I can do engineering.
That could be exciting.
I can build a robot.
I don't know anything
about it, but maybe I
can build a robot that
can play tennis with me.
Here it is.
I drew a picture
of my tennis buddy
that could play tennis with me.
And I imagined buttons and
everything on the chest.
The days that I
was feeling good,
maybe I can challenge
myself-- tune the knobs
and then have really
good competition.
And the days that I'm
feeling a little bit down,
maybe I can crank it down,
so I can beat the hell out
of this thing.
So that's sort of
the idea that I had.
And I got into it.
I went to a lab when I was
an undergrad at Berkeley
and said, hey, can
I build a robot?
And the professor
didn't laugh at me
and took me on and
built the robotic legs.
And I was crazy enough
to even go to grad school
and build this thing at MIT.
I don't take all the credit.
There were a lot of grad
students working on it.
But something that I
was fascinated with
was robotic hands.
How does it actually even
learn for us to do this?
It's really amazing.
We just don't even
think about it anymore,
but the brain is doing
something to send that signal so
that we can pinch.
We can grasp.
We sometimes don't
even look at it,
and we can do amazing things.
So that's what I
was building, but I
felt like I ran
into a wall one day.
I couldn't quite
figure out what to do.
And I thought, aha.
Artificial intelligence
is not solved
because we don't
understand the human brain.
So I walked across the campus
and I went to neurosciences
and said, please take
me on because I really
need to understand
how the brain works.
And that's what I ended
up doing for my PhD.
After all of that--
tennis player robot,
neuroscience-- I
thought, OK now I
have all the tools I need
to build this tennis buddy.
But something funny happened.
I kind of started
reflecting-- what
do I want to do when I grow up?
And following this
tennis passion
didn't quite get to where
I wanted to get to anymore.
What I wanted to do by then
was to somehow really touch
different people in the world.
A lot of women feel this way.
Right?
Some inner woman in me came and
said, I want to help people.
There are lots of people
with neurological disorders
and physical disabilities
who could benefit
from things I've learned so far.
So that's what I ended up doing
as a professor for a decade,
building things like this.
This is a robotic
prosthetic device
that is controlled
by human b signal.
So whatever way we
can get the signals--
it doesn't have to be invasive
in a chip in the brain.
Sometimes it is.
And then we use that
signal to control
these sophisticated robotic
devices for those people who
lost their limbs.
So this was my research area.
And when I was in
academia, I really
wanted to push the
envelope of 30 years
down the line and the science.
What kind of dexterous
movements can we really do?
What's the secret sauce that
we have that robots are somehow
still unable to do?
But at the same time,
I have this tickle
at all time which was really
about how can we do something
for people today?
Is there a consumer
product end of this?
So I worked with a company
called Touch Bionics.
They deliver real robotic hands.
Now thousands of people are
wearing this prosthetic hand
that is controlled
by brain signal that
eventually reach the muscles.
And then that is
taken from the skin
and then is amplified to
control that prosthetic hand.
I was really trying to
help them to decode it,
so that it can not only do open
and close-- which is mostly
the standard of a
prosthetic device--
but now be able to do
maybe a pinching movement
when it's appropriate.
How do we decide
pinching versus grasping?
What are the situations?
What are the
physiological movements?
What are the brain signals
that are different when humans
are thinking about
making those motions.
So that's the kind of
things that I started to do.
But this whole idea of the
brain and machine interface
doesn't have to be about
wearable devices or body parts
replacement.
This is a picture of a robotic
device that can actually
reside completely
outside of your body.
There are a lot of
population of people--
people who had strokes, people
who have cerebral palsy,
people who have Parkinson's--
whose movements are getting
a little slower or just had an
injury and they need to recover
from it.
They have some
injuries in the brain,
and by having those people come
in and just touch the robot,
through that contact,
we built the device
that can actually start to
understand what their brain's
recovery state might be.
So anything from-- they're
not paying attention today.
There's no use in doing this.
They are getting tired.
Maybe this is not good.
They are really getting better.
Let's challenge them a
little more-- to there's
a certain set of muscles
that are activating or not
activating in the right way.
So that's the kind of
things that is also
part of this interaction
of human and machine.
And the whole idea is about
having the machine side
understanding enough
about the human
so that it can build
a whole human together
with the help of technology.
Then again I got a little itch
of getting out of the lab,
getting into people's homes.
I started a company,
incredibly unsuccessfully,
trying to build this
robotic device that
can sit in people's homes.
I started to realize
those people who
need those devices can't
even come to the lab
because they're older.
They can't move, so they have
to ask their son or daughter
to come and take a day
off to go to the hospital.
And it was a big mess.
I said, aha,
business opportunity.
This is the way to go.
So I tried to build
a robotic device that
could sit in the lab.
Technology was
totally all right,
but boy there are a lot of
other issues in executing
this to become a
consumer product.
I learned through
this that I want
to get into people's homes.
I'm really excited
to provide solutions
for people in the house.
And what can I do to do this?
So this is sort of lots and lots
of different parts of my life.
Through tennis to
my professor life,
I always came to this picture.
What is that thing that
I always come back to?
It really is to me about
the intersection of machine
and human, and
both are learning.
And because technology comes
in and learns how humans work,
it allows humans to be whole.
And I did this, as I said, in
more of the university domain.
I built the center called the
Center of Sensorimotor Neural
Engineering.
This is an effort
by over 100 faculty
and over 300 students
across the country.
The hub is in Seattle.
They're receiving tens
of millions of dollars
to do the research-- anywhere
from building the chip that
can go in a brain without really
harming people all the way
to animal studies, human
studies, robotic device
building.
And then collaborating
all of that
together, so that it can spin
off companies to effect people.
So that was a great effort.
Another thing that I
built was a nonprofit.
So this is a nonprofit
called YokyWorks.
Throughout being
visible in this world,
I started to get emails
from people who said,
well my son just got
in a car accident
and just lost all the
sensation from his hand.
Is there anything you
can do because you're
doing research in this area?
And I thought, there
are ways that maybe I
can help those people.
And a lot of younger women,
even in junior high school,
they start to get
interested in solving
these problems in some way.
So I got together a whole bunch
of volunteers, aged anywhere
from 12 to 60, doing finance to
management to engineering work
to physical therapy
as a team to solve
specific problems
for specific people.
So this is actually
an incredibly place.
And if you're interested
in efforts like that,
please do let me know
afterwards as well.
Then on to-- of course you're
here sitting at Google.
I'm here at Google now.
I just want to how you about
how this yin-yang fits into what
I'm working on now
at Google and Nest.
This is a picture of a
nice home where I said,
I'd love to get in and do
nice things for people.
This is a family who want
to achieve a lot of things.
What are the things that
we can do with technology
that I can help with?
So I teamed up with the
co-founders of Nest-- Tony
Fadell, who was a
godfather of iPod,
and my student, Matt Rogers
from Carnegie Mellon,
who is also co-founder
of Nest, who
was kind of the key engineer for
building the iPod and iPhone.
And they know how to
build beautiful things.
I knew how to work with
people to make devices
to learn to enhance
what people can do.
So we really became a
company that reinvents things
in people's homes--
important things,
essential even, but
pretty much ignored.
They don't need to be ugly
or dumb, so ours aren't.
Ours think, and they learn.
And that's why
they're beautiful.
So this is exactly
what we're after.
We started off
with a thermostat.
And this is certainly
pretty to look at.
But the word thermostat--
even the first time
I heard from Tony and
Matt thermostat-- I said,
what, that dusty, yucky thing?
What are you talking about?
But I want you to watch
this video for a second.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
You know what's interesting?
As we started off
saying thermostat,
what I really
didn't know is that
in homes, the thermostat
that the human touches spends
about 44% of the US
residential energy bill.
That's really, really big.
We worry about-- oh,
I forgot to turn off
the light in the house.
Well, that's 11%.
This fridge is making this
crazy, growling noise.
Maybe I should set the
temperature little bit lower.
That's 9%.
This heating and cooling is 44%.
It is a giant problem.
And if we can do
this in a smart way--
because whenever I ask people,
do you want to save energy?
Everybody says yes.
But somehow we might not
be doing the right thing.
So why can't technology come
into the picture and help
people achieve who
they want to be?
So that's exactly what we do.
And then throughout our
process, we can do updates.
We released this
device over two years
ago now with features such as
Auto-Schedule and Auto-Away.
Auto-Schedule is all
about understanding
when people around,
when people are not,
what temperature people
like, and come up
with the temperature profile
throughout the week that
saves energy for you as
well as to keep comfort.
But people have different
schedules every week,
so having a rigid
schedule doesn't work.
Not only does the Auto-Schedule
keep learning over time,
but also some
special night-- you
go out for poker night
on Wednesday night
with your buddies--
Auto-Away kicks in.
It says, ooh, unusual.
I don't see anybody.
I think we should
just save more energy.
All of that together is working
well along with Nest Leaf.
The leaf that you
saw on the video
encourages people to
actually try to see the leaf.
It's like mini-gaming,
but it's not
in your face kind of gaming.
It turns out something
like-- I can't remember
the exact number-- but something
like over 80% of people
check to see if they
have a leaf daily
on their app on their phone.
So it's something
that just makes
you feel like I'm saving energy.
Oh no, I should turn
a little bit more.
Oh yeah, a see it.
Great.
I even saw texts going
across from friends saying,
I have one more leaf than
you this month, ha ha.
So it's kind of a good thing.
But you know what?
As we went in, and as we started
to get more data about how
the houses worked and how
the HVAC systems worked,
we realized that the
opportunity is really big.
There's a human behavior
aspect, but there's also
learning about people homes.
So we released a
feature called Airwave.
We noticed that
air conditioners--
and if we think
about it, maybe it's
obvious-- the air conditioner
blows really cold air.
And if the fan
and the compressor
both stop at the same
time, the cold air
that's stuck in
the duct is wasted.
So we found out through
an intelligent way
how long for each home to keep
blowing the air a little bit
longer.
Sometimes it's
for eight minutes.
And we actually end up using
much less air conditioner time,
so therefore less energy
to cool people's homes.
Also we kept learning
more and more.
And we not only save energy,
but we bring comfort.
When people say
they want it to be
70 degrees at 7:00
in the morning,
we have this thing called
Early-On especially
for cold places.
Maybe all of us don't
really appreciate
it living here as much.
When a lot of people
wake up at 7:00,
they just want to be warm.
Otherwise it's really
difficult to get of the bed.
We have a feature
called Early-On.
Again, we look at the
thermal profile of the home,
know exactly how early
to turn on the heating.
So by the time you
get out of the bed,
it's at the temperature
that you like.
So there's a lot of geeky stuff
inside this beautiful device
that we keep delivering
over and over.
And even things called Sun
Block-- we saw in data one day
and said, wait a second.
What's this crazy
spike of temperature
that just happens for 30
minutes in the morning?
And because the thermostat
thinks it's so hot,
it was preventing
heating to kick in.
Well of course when
the sun is directly
hitting that thing
on a wall, it just
doesn't know really how warm
or cool it is in a room.
We found a way, again,
to counteract that.
Therefore it knows the
real room temperature,
and the heating can kick in.
So you can imagine, we
keep finding fun things
in the data that allow us
iterate over and over to learn
about people and learn about
houses-- to do the right thing.
So what's interesting is that
we originally only sold it
in the US, but somehow people
managed to buy it and then
install it in their
own countries.
This number actually might
be out of date by now,
but quite a lot of people
installed it everywhere
in the world.
Also people started to say
things that are weird like,
I love my thermostat.
I mean, come on.
Who would have said that before?
It's kind of nice to hear that.
Also a lot of people realized
that bills are actually
getting smaller and smaller.
I even got a text from
one of my best friends
in Boston three days ago
saying, thank you Nest.
And then it just had a
snapshot of their bill.
And those are the things that
really make me smile every day.
Overall we are everywhere.
You can buy this from Amazon,
Best Buy, Lowe's, Home Depot--
if you're a Google
employee get a 25 discount.
Stuff like that, so
it's really great.
We have saved over-- this
is kind of funny to read--
either one billion
kilowatt hours,
one million megawatt hours,
or one terawatt hours.
It's sort of a funny
thing to count.
But somehow energy folks like
to count it in kilowatt hours,
so we go by one
billion kilowatt hours.
And that's how much,
as of last September,
that Nest devices
together have saved.
And that's about
equivalent to the energy
that Hoover Dam produces
in three months.
[APPLAUSE]
That's pretty good.
So as you can see, we are moving
toward helping people achieve
who they want to be through
just a thing called thermostat.
But--
[ALARM]
Oh jeez.
What is that?
Where did it come from?
So we live with this device.
Right?
You've experienced
this at 3:00 AM.
And you go, oh come on, honey.
Wake up and figure
out where that is.
And take that damn
thing off the wall.
Actually it's funny because
it happened to me last night,
but I was too tired
to even say honey.
It wakes me up every
five minutes, but OK.
So that tells you that I didn't
have my Nest installed yet.
So it turns out people do worry
about fire and carbon monoxide
in the house.
This is one of the big things
that people worry about.
But even though
you worry about it,
you install this thing
which is annoying.
You hate it.
It's ugly.
There are constant false alarms.
You take a shower, and it rings.
And you cook, and it doesn't
know that you have visitors.
And it just goes off.
So why isn't it done right?
It seems like a ripe
opportunity for Nest to look at.
Here's one thing.
So if you look at all the
homes that burned down,
73% of the homes actually
had either missing, dead,
or disconnected batteries.
That's what you do.
Right?
If you get this annoyed,
you remove the battery,
or you take it off the wall.
And then that feels good.
It's like, OK, problem solved.
Well, no.
The problem is not solved.
So we introduced Nest
Protect last year.
And watch this video again.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Heads up.
There's smoke in
the dining room.
Smoke alarm hushed.
Heads up.
There's smoke in the bedroom.
Emergency, there's smoke
in the living room.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
YOKY MATSUOKA: It almost makes
me cry every time I see it.
I don't know what it is.
Our marketing
people are awesome.
But let me just go
over some of the things
that we did overcome.
SMOKE DETECTOR VOICE: Heads up.
There's smoke in
the living room.
The alarm may sound.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Don't
you hate it when
the alarm is the first
thing that spears your ears?
So we warn you ahead of time.
And how long we warn
you ahead of time
depends on the
profile of the smoke.
SMOKE DETECTOR VOICE: Heads up.
There's smoke in
the living room.
The alarm may sound.
Smoke alarm hushed
in the living room.
YOKY MATSUOKA: Another
thing that we also
hate is to look for the
ladder, jump up, find a stick.
We got rid of that with
the gesture recognition.
SMOKE DETECTOR VOICE: There's
carbon monoxide in the den.
There's carbon
monoxide in the den.
YOKY MATSUOKA: And we
tell you which room it is.
And then we are
interconnected, so you
can hear it from anywhere when
the dangerous situation is
going on.
SMOKE DETECTOR VOICE: Smoke
is clearing in the kitchen.
YOKY MATSUOKA: This
is a really good one.
I love this because you know
that feeling of the hair
standing in your
back feeling like,
is it going to go off again?
I got rid of the bacon, but
Well we got rid of that too.
So again, looking
at the smoke profile
from many different
situations, we
found a good time to
basically tell you,
you know what, it's
going to be OK.
You don't have to
worry that it's
going to go off for a while.
So we also tell you that.
Another thing you think
about-- that thing
you have on your ceiling-- and
say, is this really working?
I have no idea.
We try to remove that
feeling completely.
Some of the sensors are being
checked every 40 seconds.
And we actually
specifically make
sure that you know about
this through the app.
So whenever you're in doubt--
is that thing working?
You can go and
then you can indeed
see green circles, yellow
circles, or gray circles
depending on the status.
As well as at night
time, every time you
switch a room light off, we
try to show a status light.
This is a really nice.
You don't have to
check on the app.
Every night you turn off
the light, and you look up.
And you say, OK, great.
All the sensor checks throughout
the day have all worked out.
And then when it's
orange, you actually
walk up and wave again.
And it tells you the status of
exactly what might be wrong,
including low battery status.
And finally-- something we
didn't think we would love,
but that ones I have my house
I absolutely love-- it sort of
acts as a path light.
It's sitting there.
And why not?
It's in very perfect opportunity
places-- entrance to the bed
room, close to the
bathroom, in the kitchen.
When I want to go and
get water at night time,
I used to just go in and
sort of go with the touches.
Now I can actually see things.
It's really nice.
Finally-- this is something
from the machine learning
perspective that I actually
love-- now we can actually
get help for the thermostat
through the smoke detector.
For example, now because there
are other smoke detectors
in the house that can also
see your general house status,
we can do Auto-Away which is
to know when to go and start
saving energy much better.
So it's not just
from one location
where the thermostat is.
We can understand the whole
house situation better.
As well as when that
carbon monoxide alarm
is going on the
Nest Protect side--
if the heating is
turned on and running,
that's over 50% of the cause
of the carbon monoxide.
We can communicate that and
turn off for you right away.
You can see the beginnings of
the benefits of having multiple
of those in your house
and start to understand
what might be going on.
As you can see, we are walking
toward this beautiful home
where people can
really stay smart, try
to achieve who they want to be,
and we're helping that happen.
So I come back to
this picture and think
about all the questions
people asked before.
Well, what do you want
to be when you grow up?
And I feel like I had many
different chapters in my life
where I ended up doing
different things.
But what I'm working
on-- if they asked me,
and if I knew about this path--
this is what I wanted to do.
And I'm really excited
I'm working on it.
Also I now have four
kids, and the older two
are actually girls.
And I just started asking
these questions to them.
So I'm kind of excited to
see what's going to happen,
how their answer
is going to evolve,
and how many chapters
they might end up having.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Questions?
I think there are
folks with microphones.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much for
this wonderful presentation.
I really like the product
that Nest is doing.
I think I've read a lot about
probably the interaction why
Google bought Nest, but
I want your perspective.
Google is about search.
It's about giving information.
Now with this technology--
thermostats in the house,
getting all the coolness
of helping people
to manage their temperature,
what you should want
about carbon monoxide-- what
is Google after with Nest?
YOKY MATSUOKA: I can't
answer what Google is after.
But I think what we're after
is to make our life easier,
better, and smarter.
And you know that's
what Google wants too.
It turns out us working
together can really
get closer to that dream.
AUDIENCE: Hi, a quick
question on the power
usage for both the Nests.
I know you use the
Nest thermostat
to reduce energy
usage in the house.
How much energy do each of the
Nests use in turn to operate?
YOKY MATSUOKA: The Nest itself?
The Nest itself uses
very little energy.
It's 20 milliwatts.
It's sleeping most of the time.
So actually it is doing
what's called power stealing.
And most of time it's sleeping.
It has a rechargeable
battery that we slowly
charge as needed.
So it's really, really small.
Onto the energy bills--
actually for the HVAC portion
it's up to 20%.
And then the overall bill
because it's about 50%
of energy costs, it's about 10%.
AUDIENCE: So Nest is
made for the home.
Do you offer commercial
products for office buildings?
Or have you thought about
energy use in data centers
and tying into building
management systems?
YOKY MATSUOKA: Thanks
for the question.
I can't answer a
lot of the future,
but we're thinking
about everything.
Things that are more
similar to people's homes,
like small business, is easier
to get into in the near future.
AUDIENCE: Are there
any plans to integrate
Nest with home security systems?
Like people can
get notifications
from different angles?
YOKY MATSUOKA: That
sounds like a great idea.
Thanks for the idea.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
All these devices-- you said you
see interesting things in data,
and I realize it's a research
stage-- when they are
installed, how do you
update your software inside?
If you do, do you collect
any data from devices
to continue to improve?
I mean is it centrally
collected somewhere?
Do you have access to devices?
YOKY MATSUOKA: We handle
data very, very carefully,
so carefully that we even
have a hard time accessing it
sometimes.
But yes, we have
sensors in the device.
The thermostat has temperature,
humidity, occupancy, light,
and proximity sensors.
And then the smoke side
has similar ones as well--
carbon monoxide and smoke.
And then we do
collect them and try
to understand thermal models,
people's behavior, and all
of that.
Again, we do it in
a very careful way
so that the security issue is
minimized as much as possible.
One last one.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm not going to ask about Nest.
I'm going to ask
about what do you
want to do when you grow up?
I had this conversation
my eight-year-old sister.
And she was like, an engineer.
I was, awesome.
But once we were talking
about time traveling.
I was like, do think
we can do that?
She was like,
absolutely, of course.
I was like, well
if it's absolutely,
why we don't have it so far?
She was like, well scientists
are busy with other inventions.
And then they get busy
with other inventions.
And then they put it on hold.
And then they forget.
I was like, then we're
never going to get it.
And she's like, then
why don't we do it?
Me and you, let's form a team.
I told her, how?
And she was like, we're going
to hire a genius guy to do it.
I'm like, what?
Why?
Why not us?
And she is like, well
do you see a girl's lab?
I see Dexter's Lab on TV.
I've never seen a
girl do science.
I was like, if the
TV didn't show it,
it doesn't mean
it doesn't exist.
She was like, I always wanted
to know more about space,
and I even searched YouTube.
YouTube is not TV, and I
found guys going to space.
I didn't find girls
going to space.
And even though she is
interested in engineering
because I studied computer
engineering and my dad
is an engineer, she really
thinks her options are still
limited to what she's
seeing on TV, on YouTube,
or what other girls
around her doing.
So what do you think we
should do towards this?
I mean eight-year-old kids
are thinking this way.
YOKY MATSUOKA: I love the
question, and I love the story.
And it is so true.
Isn't it?
One, I love the fact
that you came here
because this is one of the
big steps that we can take.
We all know this problem.
So I actually heard a
talk by Geena Davis,
who absolutely believes in
changing even from Hollywood.
So Disney movies, the
things that little kids--
they don't mean to, but they
watch it and get influenced
by it-- she said only 17% of
the characters are female.
17% percent of the leading
roles-- even in Disney movies,
even in animation-- are girls.
When they hire extras in the
background, they are 17% girls.
What's wrong with that?
Our eyes start to
get used to the fact
that the world is full of men.
Something has to change.
Right?
So all of us can
make those changes.
And I think we've got to do it.
One step at a time,
but I think we've
got to look from all angles.
The other one that's interesting
is my girls are the same.
They say they want
to become scientists.
Apparently 70% of
girls and boys say
that around the age of
third grade and fifth grade.
Then if you ask
the same question
by the time they get to the
ninth grade-- by the way,
the stats came from the
National Science Foundation--
only about 30% of girls say
they want to be scientists.
For the boys side,
still 60% of them
say they want to be scientists.
So something happens in that
span, some influence that
comes from outside that makes
them think that maybe they
can't do it.
Maybe it's puberty, but maybe
it's something that they watch.
I think we all
should pay attention
to that period of
time and make sure
that number doesn't become 30.
It should stay closer
to the number of boys.
And I love to work with that.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]